hi everyone
hello
[Music]
we are just waiting a few more minutes
until we get started
[Music]
to the ones who are already like in the
chat and
so who of you has attended last week's
workshop where we like fine-tuned our
model
cool a lot of new people awesome so it's
like it doesn't matter that you haven't
been um there last week so we are not
like building on something we have
created last week it's like completely
something
from scratch
so um
we can we can put the discord link
because we are accepting the questions
from there
um let me post it
okay great i think we can start with the
introduction and then for the folks
who's like joining a bit late it doesn't
matter since we are just giving like a
bit insights on who we are and what we
are going to do so welcome from our side
to our second workshop and going
production where we are deploying and
scaling monitoring i mean first
transformer models on aws h maker as
well as running some batch transform
shop and today joining me is nate
who will take care of all of your
questions which are going to be asked on
discord or in the chat
um
she will do the session about batch
transform and then myself and mathieu
from aws
so welcome to our our workshop
and here again the quick links um mervy
has already shared the discord link we
also have a very active community forum
on discuss huggingface.co with a
separate section for sagemaker so if you
have any questions about hugging face on
sagemaker after the workshop or like in
a few months feel free to open a thread
there and all of the code which we are
going to show today are is available on
github and on the repository
shared there
i guess but you can take over and give a
short introduction yep we will do a
first introduction for sagemaker so for
the people that was there uh
at the previous session it will be a bit
of repeat but i will go faster
for you
but if you didn't uh join the first
session i think it could be useful so
let's go for that
so
the adobe's vision uh for the machine
learning it's to make the machine
learning accessible to all the customer
they if you are developer data scientist
or business user
uh
the uh
we sign a very strong
partnership with aginface to make the
nlp easy and accessible for all
and
as you know like hugging face is the
most popular
open source company that provides a
state-of-the-art nlp and on the other
hand you have
the sagemaker offer from aws that give
you a high performance resource for
training your models
the iws ml stack is composed of three
layers so at the bottom layer you have
all the infrastructure parts where you
will provide like a gpu but also custom
chip for the inference
and
and also docker container uh especially
built for the deep learning on the the
upper stack the ii services is where you
are only developer and you want to put
like more intelligence on your website
and we have a bunch of services that
help you to do translate
sentiment analysis but also focus
recognition
for images
and on the middle stack that is like the
most important for you is sage maker and
sage maker is a tool to help data
scientists to go from the id to the
production that will be a big focus
today and so we provide a lot of tools
that help you
going from a notebook
to a production endpoint where you can
make the inference and on that stack of
sagemaker we include again face as a
custom as a framework that is fully
supported by aging phase with what we
call the dlc the deep learning container
and so uh
we gonna go through the introduction of
the again phase deep learning container
so he help you to
to train
and do the inference and whatever
frameworks you are using if it spiked or
should sensor probably will work
we have an estimator that is directly
integrated to the sagemaker sdk so it's
really easy to use and uh and you can
start a cost effective job for training
without worrying about docker
we have a comprehensive
gallery of example and everything is
support and maintained by adwords so if
you already have a super substitution
for your duplicate seconds
you will benefit from uh
from adware's support even for again
phase training job and inference
so the benefit of running again face on
site maker will be cost effectively
because you can leverage
some container that is deeply optimized
for
again phase training
we have spot instance
if you want to leverage those for a
non-critical workload
we we follow the envelopes
strategy so you can automate everything
inside sagemaker from the meta store the
logistics
inside cloud watch
you have the monitoring and the profiler
and of course experiment it's really
scalable so you can spin up
any gpus
that you need and to do parallelism but
you will also can
can downscale if you don't have a maybe
user during the night or something and
of course everything that we do at aws
security is like job zero for us
so you can leverage
the vpc connectivity and the
fine-grained ein permission for securing
your workload
so
again face
again on sagemaker is like a really a
top quality
container that we develop
with
with again face
and it will remove the heavy lifting of
of managing a nicer
registry i have custom installation and
sdk so we will really streamline the
process uh for using your interface
on sagemaker
so the way that it works is like you
build your model
by leveraging sagemaker notebook but it
could also be the the studio or your own
ide that you use on your yoko machine
you will start a training using the dlc
and that dlc will uh
will pull uh the
the models and all the frameworks from
again face you will uh
from there fine-tune uh your model and
manage your experiment and after when
you have done and that you have your
model that is trained you can uh deploy
it using sagemaker endpoints
or and automatically leverage the
scaling of that model and we will have a
deeper
dive today on that or you can download
it directly from
s3 and host it yourself
so now uh we can get your hand dirty i
forgot to update the
the ash code so it's the wrong one but
you will have it uh philip just share it
in the chat
and so you go to that link that is the
dashboard event engine so you will land
on this page you put the edge code just
there
and that will uh with that you will be
able to access one adobe seconds so for
the signing methods uh you can choose
the the email one-time password
so from there
you can type
your email
you will receive an email with the
one-time password
waiting for again and you land on the
the team dashboard
from there you can click the address
console button
and then
click open adobe's console
from here you access your
temporary icons inside adws
and on the top bar you can search for
sage maker
[Music]
and go to the search maker service
page
here we already spin up some notebook
that you can access so you click a
notebook and then a notebook instance
and here you have four notebooks so you
can pick one
the only thing is like you are four by
accounts so when you choose one you will
need to take care that someone else
didn't
took it before
so you click open jupiter
and that will already accu to the
jupiter notebook
for that and from there you can click on
running
here to see if someone else uh have
already
start a notebook
if it's not the case you can go to the
second workshop
the lab one
for for the first
demonstration
and stop the notebook
and here you have the first notebook and
not that if i come back here
and i refresh
there
okay
you have the green
book that say that is already running so
if it's the case and you see the green
book or uh the the notebook there you
just go back to the searchmaker console
and you pick another notebook
and so i will end up tonight
to start digging
dive deep into that notebook
actually we're going over to uh mirva
today oh marvin yeah sorry for that
the floor is yours no problem
maybe before we get started you guys
just see like a few questions coming in
the channel to access and
are the hash working for you or is there
something like um
say saying what errors i saw that toby
has an error with throttling exception
right exceeded and also michael uh
um
don't know how to come to the console
okay michael managed to works okay it
works hash works works perfect
okay and devin when you're like a team
dashboard uh you can click on open
console and then go to uh search for
sagemaker at the search bar and then you
should come in as the sagemaker notebook
yes just on top here
should i start
yes
this is yours okay
let me show my skin
okay you can see my screen right
yes
um
so today uh last week we have uh we have
trained the model successfully and
deployed it and this week we are going
to do a batch inference with batch
transform
so
our problem is
our data consists of tweets
and these tweets have sentiments and we
are going to
classify the sentiments of those tweets
um
there is a i'm going to start with
pre-processing and then tell you how to
set up the transformer
so firstly you start with uh starting
the sagemaker session and then get the
exec get execution roll for the user
roles and
set up your s3 bucket
and we have this tweet data we are going
to turn it into a json lines file
uh here
uh it's just we are transforming it into
a different format
and we are going to upload it to uh
to s3 with s3 uploader
we are just
creating this bucket and in this bucket
we have this batch transform input
folder and batch transform output folder
and our tweets look like this
so if you have previously trained the
model with a hugging face estimator
already
you can directly uh create the
transformer for that estimator
uh you have just trained your model with
and if that is that is actually your
model sorry
and then call the transform on it
you can still
use the use the models in the hub
so let us
go through the notebook
so
i'm going to
i'm going to i have just uploaded uh
transformed the
csv file and uploaded to the s3 bucket
and i'm going to create this uh
transformer to run the bat job from uh
but for this time i'm going to take the
model from the hub
so i'm going to have this
environmental variable
uh hugging face model id this is the
this is our model
and we are going to give the task which
is text classification here
and we are going to create the hugging
face model
so we give the environmental variables
roles
uh transformers version pytorch version
and python version
uh we create the transformer uh that we
will call later call our batch
uh transform a bit
so i am giving uh instance count
instance type output paths
which i have just created above
and the strategy which is single record
meaning that we will we will send
one
uh one example in every request
so
i'm going to
run this
and
to uh do the inference in a data set
because in the in the in the batch
transform you pass a data set you do
this in batches
uh
to pass the data set i'm going to take
the output file and um i'm going to i'm
going to download the output file
and then uh
i'm sorry
uh i'm going i'm going to get my uh i'm
going to get my results by doing uh
by downloading uh the
the the result of the batch transform
which was in the output path so i have
downloaded it with s3
and i got my inferences
which is basically uh the label one is
positive label zero is negative these
are the confidences
so yeah
philip would you like to explain this
yeah sure thanks so um when you like so
we we are doing two since lab one would
be basically just like uh creating a
real-time endpoint which nate has done
in the last section but feel free to do
like one if you are interested in like
after the workshop you will have um
access to the um temporary account i
think from
60 more minutes after the workshop is
done
and so you can run lab one as well and
when running lap two when you execute a
batch transform job um it will take a
few min minutes until like the instance
um is spawned up and then run the batch
job and what we can see here on the
visualization is basically an
explanation of how um aws stage make a
batch transform is working behind the
scene so
we have a real-time endpoint which you
can like easily deploy to sagemaker and
then send http requests back and forth
but um for real-time endpoints the
instance is basically up 24 7 so you
would pay um the duration of the
instance time being up and that's
basically nice if you have like
real-time application but a lot of
enterprises are still in the process of
hanging batch shops where you run like
predictions overnight or like once a
week to like update your database for
example with a new model and that's
where batch transform can chime in
and batch transform basically works um
as we see here we have like one instance
in this case and the instance consists
out of an agent and which is basically a
python script um ec set and the model
the model is a real-time endpoint we
know from just deploying a real-time
endpoint and the agent is basically the
plane of our batch transform job it will
load our uploaded json line data set
from s3 and then iterates through it
like so we have like a json line data
file with maybe hundreds of thousands of
um
inputs and the agent will iterate
through it and send one http request per
row to our model endpoint and saves the
output or the prediction of this line
into a new json line file which will be
at the end uploaded to s3 so the whole
process is basically you provide
a data file a json line data file and
start a batch transform job the agent
will iterate over it sends the request
to the model endpoint and creates a new
output json line file which will be
uploaded to s3 and then sagemaker will
take care of stopping everything at the
end and it's also possible um to scale
up to multiple instances so if you are
like not running like on a few hundred
or a few thousand inputs you could
easily scale up your bets transform top
to two four or even eight instances and
then like the data will be spread evenly
for multiple files and then it's way
faster to iterate and you will only pay
for the duration of your batch transform
job and if you check your locks and when
after the execution of batch transform
job you can see that it's like simple
http request sending to our model
endpoint okay um yeah
thank you uh we have a couple of
questions
yeah maybe to ask amir khan's question
so what about the tokenizer so um as you
can see if not scrolls up a bit where we
define our hub configuration with a
model id
and and the task and this will also load
the tokenizer from hugging from from the
hugging face-up and then our inference
dlc
load the tokenizer loads the model and
then runs the prediction by itself
i think it's around here that i have
loaded the pipeline
yeah in here
and you give the when you give the task
it also
loads the
it and the model id it also loads the
tokenizer
um and then to answer hanos question how
do i use the model not in the hub so
instead of providing when creating the
hugging phase
model class from the sagemaker sdk
currently we defined the nth
parameter with the hub configuration and
instead of providing the nth parameter
you can provide a model data which is an
s3 ui where your artifact is stored you
can also um go to the github
of hugging phase with called notebooks
there's like a there's like a whole
stage maker section um with examples for
batch transform jobs or deploying two um
sagemaker to real real-time endpoints
using s3 artifacts instead of a hugging
phase model hub model
also in the beginning of the notebook
there is an example of uh
how you train from
scratch i mean it's it's not how you
train from scratch but if you have
trained from scratch and not from
not have you haven't taken your model
from the hub
how you can perform this
is given in the beginning of the
notebook
okay can we have like a message in the
chat for those who started their batch
transform job already how hard jobs
going
and if you have any questions at all
just feel free to drop them in the chat
here guys
perfect there we have like our first
finish successfully that's amazing
and maybe to like to explain a bit more
why we are like converting the csv file
to a json line file it's basically um
csv is just like um column based and
since we are working with text it's like
oftentimes you have for example the
delimiter of your columns in a csv
inside your text so attacks can easily
contain like a colon or like some
special characters and then this could
like basically screw the the data
processing on the
inference side that's why we went with
json9 where we have our dedicated inputs
and also um additional parameters so the
batch transform job is not only working
with text classification for example you
could also do like zero shot
classification and then you couldn't
even like represent it properly inside a
csv since we are having like the inputs
and then our like candidates for our
label which is also an array and
working with
like nested areas inside json is not
very nice
and
maybe there's a few questions is there
any limit of fetch
i mean what do you mean with a limit
limit in time and like fire size limit
or a duration limit or
no there's no limit like if your json
line file has instead of like the few
hundred rows in our example like a few
thousands or few hundred thousand rows
then the batch transform shop is just
running longer that's all
and then maybe for vince news question
and
yeah of course you can like use q4
pipelines but i think you would need to
like create your own container and like
scripts to work with it i'm not sure if
you can like easily use the shmaker dlcs
for that inside of cubeflow
so that's something you would need to
try out
okay
then
i would start sharing my screen and we
would go to
let free which is
like the the lab where we are going to
scale
our yeah inference and monitor it so
basically let three is similar to lab
one where you create in real time
endpoint except that in lab three we are
going to
add additional configuration to auto
scale our endpoint and to directly look
into the
um monitoring dashboards created by
cloudwatch
and be free to ask like all of the
questions we will have some slots when
going through the example where we can
answer them and you can find the the
notebook
again in workshop two and then it's like
three um auto scaling and for this
example make sure we have like a higher
stage maker version than uh 2.6
installed because we released the new
dlc version supporting like the latest
transformers version so i have done this
already just to check again i have like
a nice higher version and then what we
are here doing is basically
creating a real-time endpoint
so we again pick up our im role have
we we will use again a hugging face hub
model in this case we are using a fin
bird model which is nice because i guess
it's more real world oriented it's fine
tune on a lot of like financial text
corpus to estimate the sentiment that's
why we go with this model you can find
it on the hub and then our task is again
text classification for the name and i
will use the
second part of our
hacking phase id and then just a uuid to
make sure that we are like creating all
of the models and then we are again
creating our hackingfest model class
with our hub configuration and in this
case if you like already have a model on
s3 you could replace the end with the
model data pointing to the s3 ui we
provide our role
the endpoint name and we are using
transformers four point eleven pi charge
1.9 and python 3.8 and then we are
creating our endpoint with the dot
deploy method to a c5 instance which is
a compute optimized instance with an
intel cascade lake and we are also
defining one variable we need later for
accessing our cloud watch and dashboards
directly from the notebook so it's just
the aws region where
your
endpoint is being deployed
and then for those who don't know
basically what's happening behind the
scenes when creating a real-time
endpoint so here you can see
the like the software structure of our
inference dlc the inference dlc is the
hosting service
where we use the multi model server
which is an aws created machine learning
serving um yeah system based on java on
the
neti framework which provides the i and
also when you are sending a request to
the elc we have these emails this mms
interface
written in java which will accept the
request and also respond the request but
then after
nettie has received the request it
starts python worker so the
prediction and the inference code is
written in python but the whole wrapper
the i o wrapper around it is based on
the multi-modal server and neti and the
inference toolkit is an open source um
implementation you can also find it on
github and it's based on the hugging
phase transformer pipeline so basically
it's an optimized wrapper for stage
maker for the hacking phase pipeline so
for example if you have like a project
with the client and want to showcase a
model you can load it with the hugging
face pipeline and then if you want to
like create an end point you can
basically provide the hugging face id
and the task and then you will get a
similar interface
then you have with the pipelines and the
inference toolkit also supports all of
the quarks so if you are working with a
generalization tag like a task like
summarization or translation you can
provide like the additional
arguments as parameters for like um
penalties or max length or min flanks
these can all directly be provided
inside the
uh request and you can find more or
basically all inference parameter on the
acme phase dot co slash doc stage maker
side there's a separate section for
inference
and then what the inference toolkit is
basically doing it's idle loading the
model from the hugging face hub or from
s3 initializing and then depending on if
it's a tensorflow model it uses
tensorflow if it's a pi touch model it
uses python pytorch and then initializes
the pipeline and um serves the the
request so when a request comes in
mms accepts it make sure it's correct
passes into the inference toolkit which
runs a pipeline which passes the
incoming inputs and parameters to make
sure we have everything we want runs the
prediction and then responds back to
the mms and then to the client
and
yeah and that's basically what happens
on the search maker side
so that we are like having um our
developer who either uploads a model to
s3 or to the hiking phase hub creates
our stage maker model provides the
endpoint configuration and creates the
model this edge maker model here is
is our hacking phase hub
model
and then the end point configuration
currently includes the instance tile and
the instance count and while i was
talking through it the end point got
deployed successfully and we can run
predictions on it and our example is
there's a shortage of capital for
project sage maker we need extra
financing so i hope mateo can help us on
this so we can scale our financing and
the model correctly predicts its
negative
and to showcase the model monitoring a
bit i will run over a loop of 500 and uh
yeah items and then like send the same
request
to the endpoint to show you in a minute
how model monitoring is going to look
like
do we have any questions of our name
yeah there's a question
can the endpoint be accessed outside of
sagemaker notebook
for example can we hit it with post
requests with something like postman
yeah so each stagemaker endpoint is
exposed as http api but it requires um
aws seek for four authorization so the
easiest way to access or to work with a
sagemaker endpoint is using the awsh sdk
where you have different clients for
different languages so in python it
would be go to free and with the
sagemaker invocation client and then you
can like invocate it from anywhere you
want it's the same for java and go or
like node for example and also what you
could do is um
wrap aws lambda function around your
sagemaker endpoint so you would create
like a aws lambda function deploy your
sagemaker endpoint and then permission
the aws lambda function to
be being able to invocate your end point
and then you could um like
request the lambda function from
basically anywhere you want and then the
lambda function will um call the
stagemaker endpoint we have also an
example for this i'm happy to share you
afterwards
sure i'm trying to see if there's any
other questions i didn't answer in the
chat
um oh does inference serving
architecture support aws's
inf1 instances
uh i've read that this is four times
faster but hasn't done any tests himself
yeah so um shane i'm happy to share with
you that we are like heavily working on
supporting the
instances basically all of them and the
release should be like somewhere around
end of november so if you wait like a
few more months you can use the
inferential instances to run sagemaker
endpoints and okay
our like loop is done and now we can run
these the code cell which has like some
template strings in it and which will
generate automatically for us our um
cloudwatch link so if i click on it i
will jump directly into cloudwatch
um having the metric dashboard for our
endpoint open for those who are not
aware of or don't know cloudwatch
cloudwatch is aws like logging alerting
and metric system
which or which basically integrates very
well with all of the aws services and
then you can create like this nice
dashboards and set up alarms and in our
case we have
a dashboard for our um like incoming
requests and there we can see we started
um when we started the request and like
how it's scaled up
and the period currently is like how
it's like um grouped together is 30
seconds and like the whole timeline is
um 15 minutes so you can like adjust it
as you want and what's super nice about
it so this was created out of the box we
didn't need to configure anything at all
it will be available for each endpoint
you create you will get all of those
stage maker metrics and model monitoring
metrics and what's super nice um for
example if you want to make sure that
your model is like not not exceeding a
certain limit you could easily set up
from here with like this small little
notification bell create an alarm and i
can directly create an alarm for my end
point saying okay model latency my
period is like 10 minutes
and i had
yeah 300 requests
and i want to create an alarm when my
request number is above like
500 or something and then i can like
connect these this alarm to sns and sns
can then send like a message to slack
teams or even like to your mobile phone
as a normal message and that's like
super nice because there's like
yeah it's not a lot of work to set it up
manually and even programmatically it's
even same as
yeah the same
okay going back to our monitoring uh to
our notebook okay we have like created
our endpoint we run a few requests
already have seen okay there's like
monitoring dashboard available out of
the box but what we really want to do is
like to scale up our end point when we
get more traffic
and how auto scaling basically works
behind the scenes um stage maker
well i think my screen got a bit small
and stage maker starts um instances
and
these instances are like having a lot
balancer in front of it with the
endpoint so each request coming in from
application service or user
comes into the end point gets to the
load balancer and then it's going to be
split up across the different instances
for the example or the endpoint we
started we defined one instance and
i mean what's nice about the cloud is
that you can elastically scale up and
down depending on your usage and you are
like not wasting resources because you
don't need to run like four instances
all the time and even if you don't have
a lot of load
to create our auto scaling group we
need to define a resource id we are
using boto3 for
creating our auto scaling group
and
our resource id is basically in unique
identifier to our end point in this case
it's um
the end point
then our like endpoint name with
finbirth bird and our unique identifier
and then a timestamp then also we make
it applicable for all variants basically
and then we can create our autoscaling
target which defines okay in which
namespace we are we are in sagemaker not
an ec2 or ecs we have our resource id
we want to scale the desired instance
count so we want to scale the number of
instances running for our endpoint we
have a min capacity and a max capacity
so instead of scaling to a maximum of
four we could scale like 200 or 2 000
with like millions of requests if we
really want to
and um so we have like the definition of
okay what we want to do but we haven't
told aws how we want to do it and
therefore we need to create like auto
scaling policy which says okay scale my
auto scaling group to four instances if
something happens and this if is in our
case the sagemaker variant invocations
per week per instance
which is like a nice word for requests
coming into my instance
and the threshold i'm going to use in
this case is 10 so if we are getting
more than 10 requests to our instance
over a duration of three minutes the
auto scanning group will scale up our
endpoint to
the
desired count to like handle all of
those
requests and then we also defined a
scale in and the scale out cooldown
which basically makes sure that we are
like not over scaling all of the time
basically it's a duration or cooldown
duration after we scaled up that we are
not immediately scaling down if the
usage drops
like a minute after
and then to
show this nicely i am
running
a loop and for
260 seconds
just spamming to our endpoint that we
will exceed like the threshold for three
minutes and then the search maker will
start our
additional instances
do we have
more yeah i've got smart i got some more
questions for you um
the first one is uh which is the normal
boot time for sagemaker vm if i want to
run gptj or gpt neo model
for example in inference i'm worried
about boot time
how can i make sure i get
good throughput uh using batch transform
so it's kind of a loaded question there
yeah so so normally like creating or
starting either batch shop or real-time
endpoint takes around three to five
minutes really depending on the model
size and on the data set and if an
instance is warm already by sage maker
or not and then
after the instance is up and you start
your job it really depends on how long
the model takes to load for example such
uh gptj is like super big i think the
float 32 model is around 24 gigabytes or
something so it takes a lot of time to
load into a cpu because i guess there's
no gpu currently who fits the model i
think there's an a p4 but it's super
expensive so
you just like have all of the default
three to five minutes for stage makers
to start a job and then it depends on
what you are doing inside your training
or inside your inference batch transform
job
cool um the other question i saw was
uh can these be specified via cloud
formation templates
what
was meant with these
i'm not sure who has that
[Music]
christopher
yes so um of course it can be like you
can use cloud formation you could use
the aws cdk which is like a nice
interface for creating cloud formation
template you can also use like terraform
if you are like using terraform as
infrastructures code for your endpoint
um it's just that it's currently not
supported with the python sagemaker sdk
that we went with the photo free ones
beautiful and the last thing was do we
have any examples of using uh
lambda as you were describing earlier
yes
okay and if those are lying around um we
can link to somebody to those later
yes
cool
i think since the script is running i
can easily search for it so the lambda
example um is not using the sagemaker
sdk it's using the aws cdk and then
creating like cloud formation templates
so if you're not like familiar with cdk
which is basically a nice
infrastructure as code solution by aws
where you could use python and
typescript to create your cloudformation
templates and then deploy it and
there you can find the cdk example for
deploying an aws lambda with an api
gateway in front of it so you have like
an open available http api and also
creating a stagemaker endpoint by
providing a model id and a task
and yet the model of the video will be
recorded and to ask answer christian
berg's question and you can find it on
youtube or you can find it in discord so
if you join our discord and then go to
the um sagemaker channel when you scroll
up a bit there should be the youtube
link to the video
i'm getting the link right now anyways
so
great
okay i think any more questions folks
yeah
oh okay
still running four minutes a long time
you can ask your questions uh on the
discord channel as well after the uh
even after you have questions even if
after you have questions on the workshop
or hugging face related you can join
join our discord and
i'm going to drop a link again
uh also philip will announce uh if the
if the workshop is uploaded somewhere in
the sagemaker enterprise scale nlp
channel
yeah so we will share again the youtube
video i guess like
shortly after the whole workshop um
today in this course so you can rewatch
it again and to answer on a question and
you can access i guess you with the
server you mean like the
um temporary aws account i think it's
like 30 minutes until the workshop is
done
so 45 minutes left i think but you can
like easily run those example and
creators endpoint with your own aws
account and when you go to the github
repository in the read media's
instruction how you can create the
sagemaker notebook instance and then run
all of those examples or you can even
like run or start the endpoints from
your local machine and we have
documentation for this as well
um great question mikhail you said a
target were you took 10 how did you
determine a good what a good value is so
10 is definitely not a good value i
wouldn't recommend it to you i just went
with 10 to make sure or to showcase um
to you properly
how um how it is how it's going to work
i think a good metrics would be um you
like create your endpoint to your
dedicated um or to this desired like
instance type so if you want to go with
compute optimized c instances deploy it
to there or if you want to go with like
gpu deploy just a regular real-time
endpoint and then like run a few
hundreds of thousand requests to see
okay what can um the endpoint handle by
itself and what my average like latency
i get and there's also metrics for that
so if you if we go back quickly to our
cloudwatch dashboard and instead of
showcasing
the sample count we can go to average
and we are at model latency there we can
see our model latency per request so
here we can see the the load test i'm
currently running for the four minutes
and we can see the average model little
c for the cpu is in this case 88 sec
milliseconds so we have an instance for
c5 we use we think we have four workers
so we can send four requests in parallel
we have um per request the duration of
88 milliseconds and then you can use
like those two value to calculate the
throughput of your instance or of your
endpoint and then you can set the target
value to i think like maybe 90 or
something or even 80 so you have like
enough time to scale out or go with 60
i think it's like
i think you need to experiment it really
depends on the model you use for example
digital bird is way faster than like a
roberta large model and it really
depends on cpu or gpu and how many
workers you run
but then you can like use those numbers
to calculate your throughput and then
set the target value to
what you think is best
and
going back i can
see that it's still running
let's do
more
more questions
uh general question what are the best
ways to improve inference speed
um
i think the easiest
way is to go from cpu to gpu if you're
like just wanting to have quick results
and then there are like different
techniques on how to optimize your
models you can like if you are cpu and
also want to have like an easy example
you can um just quantize it with using
pi torch and exactly as michelle said
you can um convert your pytorch or
tensorflow models to onyx and then
optimize it and then run it there or
also inferential which will come our
support will come by the end of the week
optimizes and my notebook tricked me so
it's not like executing anymore when i i
can execute the cells and
again we can like use the photo free
library to describe our endpoint and
then print out our
the informations and as we can see it
has scaled out to for instance and with
the desired count for four and if we
execute a next line again we are jumping
into the stage maker dashboard
where we can see our endpoint
and then scroll down a bit and we can
see okay it has successfully scaled out
to
four instances
due to our request we send and now after
not sending the request like in in three
to five minutes sagemaker will again
scale down automatically
and then if you scale up or send more
requests again it will scale up again
and it's like just these cells two cells
we need to execute to enable auto
scaling on stage maker for our machine
learning models which is like i think
personally super easy to use compared to
other solutions i think out there
okay we have a few more minutes left
any open questions
i've been swatting these questions like
flies in the in the chat so uh
i don't leave you very much uh to answer
um
[Music]
are you guys using any specific inf
print server for achieving low cpu times
on your website examples uh
um
oh i think they're referring to the
inference
our inference api versus this
yeah so for the inference api like
there are two different cpu inference so
there's like the cpu acceleration you
get when i think being
a
[Music]
lab
subscriber and then we have like a
default cpu
inference and for the accelerated cpus
we are using optimize c optimization
technique it's not like onyx only it
really depends on the model on the task
and what we want to do because it's not
like you cannot say onyx works for every
model every task in nlp like it really
depends on the like the model
architecture you have is it's in in
encoder model decoder model or like a
sequence to sequence model with encoder
and decoder parts
for example they are using on it onyx
it's like not very straightforward at
all
so this question has come up a few times
uh philip uh can you clarify uh does
sagemaker have https endpoints we can
access without lambda
yeah so maybe um since we have a few
minutes left i could show you how to do
it so if we go to our stagemaker console
we are at stage maker when you enter
stage maker in the search you will enter
here and then we can go to inference and
end point and on endpoints we can see
our endpoint created
here it's in service it's real time
it's the end point where we run our
inference
and at the top it includes an http api
so in url so that's the https and point
for our stage maker uh model but you
cannot just like open any res client and
send a post request to it because these
endpoints are secured by aws seek for
authorization and
we can like easily click learn more
about it where it is described how i
described how you can and like invoke
those endpoints one example is what we
are doing with the python stagemaker sdk
is using the predictor.predict which is
creating those signature behind the
scenes and using our input but there are
also like different options on how to do
it um
so for example if i scroll down here not
this edge maker sdk is used here we are
using the photo free library where we
create a client for our stagemaker
runtime
and then we can run the client.invocate
method this like structure for creating
those
authorizations4 headers is available for
each aws sdk so it's available for java
for node.js for go for python for i
think c plus plus or something or
maybe.net as well so you can definitely
i would recommend to use those sdks if
you directly want to interact with
sagemaker endpoints and not using the
sagemaker sdk
and of course you could also like create
your own header without the sagemaker
sdk but creating those thick for
authorization headers not very like
straightforward so go with the sagemaker
the aws
sdk
and then use the um
invocation endpoint methods or just
stick with the python sagemaker sdk
and
to answer yourself a question what is
both free bottle free is
basically the aws cdkf sorry the aws sdk
for python so with photo free you can
interact with all aws services
programmatically
um how about this question can we
serialize or pickle a deployed predictor
and use it in another environment
i'm
not really sure what team means well i
think you can you can just take the the
assets the model assets you're already
kind of uploading model assets so you
could just use those anywhere you want
in any environment right yeah so we are
like not doing any specific we are
loading a model from dehydrating phase
hub and deploying it as endpoints so
instead of deploying those model to
stage maker you could deploy it like to
your local machine or to like something
else
[Music]
and um
all of those high interface models can
be uh can be deployed this way not all
of them we are working on it so the
hiking phase hub is um as you probably
have seen it's not like limited
transformers only we have like a lot of
new uh models from different frameworks
like um fast ai psychic learn um flair
and speech brain for example but all
transformers compatible models which
support nlt tasks are currently
deployable so
all of those i think 12 or 13 different
nlp pipelines are deployable and we are
working on enabling um speech pipelines
like automatic speech recognition then
you could use wave to work or uber as
well and are also working on image
classification pipelines where you could
then use vision transformers and those
should be also available like by the end
of the year so we are trying to expand
the sagemaker experience to the up those
other modalities as well
uh philip there's a question about uh
how to deploy real-time streaming
uh model with aws they're um they're
asking specifically about wave to vect
ii but i think it's more about the
architecture um can you check out that
question there
yeah um that's that's a great question
and like a super great use case to be
honest so
you said um or for those who didn't read
the chat it's like um they try to deploy
a real-time streaming wave to wack model
with aws and the initial idea was
searchmaker and then websockets with
lambda but it didn't work out well so um
web circuits with london is a great way
to create like real-time applications
um
i think you would require a lot of work
inside the lambda to like send those
requests and i think um the issue
currently with wave to wek or with the
asr pipeline is that it's like not yet
suited for like streaming so the best
way currently to use the automatic
speech recognition pipeline inside
transformers with wave to work is have
an audio file provided and then they get
the transcription back since streaming
is like a bit different kind of work
since you would need to chunk it
properly and then since you are not like
sure okay which chunks you send um it
can create some strange results but i'm
happy to share that the open source team
is like working on it on enabling
streaming and if streaming is enabled
inside the open source and for the
speech recognition pipeline it would
also be available for sagemaker
and then i think we will find a way on
how you can properly stream inputs from
ite outside of stage maker to sagemaker
either through web sockets with lambda
or like natively using the sagemaker sdk
and i saw another question from yop can
you deploy private hybrid phase models
yeah you can and so to deploy private
hugging phase models
we had the hub configuration with our
model id
and with our task
and to deploy a
private model um you just need to add a
third parameter which is hf token i
think but you can look it up in the
documentation and then you would need to
provide your hiking phase token which
has permissions to access the private
model and then those tokens will be
passed into sage maker and search maker
will then use the token to load your
private model
so it's just like providing um
your permission to sage maker
for maker to be able to download the
model
beautiful uh there's another question on
using weights and biases
um uh in the last session we actually
did the training we didn't
do that here but
when you're doing training there's the
training arguments
object and there you can just add
wand b to the
report to keyword argument which can be
found in our documentation for that
training arguments object
and i believe 1b lets you or is
expecting you to have a certain end type
file um it's you can read about it in
their documentation um
where they specify how you can give your
api key um on sagemaker but uh there's
there's a whole write up on it um
by the one b team too so you can check
that out there
okay i guess we have like we are almost
to the hour but i think we can answer
one more last question so
who wants to have the honor okay there
we got one so can you deploy custom
models even they are not uploaded to the
hub right yeah so you can like deploy
any transformers nlp compatible model to
sagemaker either through the hub
directly or through s3 and in the
documentation you can find
instructions on how to do it there are
like notebooks on hanging face notebooks
repository where you can also find
examples on how to deploy a model from
s3 to sagemaker
great then thank you for participating
and
yeah happy to talk to you um
hopefully seeing some of you on discord
or on the hugging face forum
and then
until next time
thank you again bye thanks everybody